it's real name is really rather long
I've got all day
sharp get it on the screen so we could
read it out because there's a ChemDraw
picture of it and I could read it out
and its formal name is bisby's and
trimethylsilyl amino diphenyl phosphor
ah no method I'd uranium IO dough
toluene died so that is this compound
right here
so my colleagues Steve little the
uranium man has just published the paper
and he's made a new compound with two
uranium atoms in it quite complicated
but it has one interesting property and
I want to tell you about that this one
is the the main subject of the paper
which we've just published it's a really
really intense dark blue color it's so
blue that you actually when you look at
it you think it's black to begin with
you have to think about the hard disk in
your computer or if you've got an
old-fashioned iPod inside there as well
which uses magnetic material to record
the notes and ones that make up digital
signals for your music or your computer
programs or whatever and it does this by
having small regions that are magnetic
and they behave just like a little
magnet with the North and the South Pole
and they can point one way for a nought
and the other way for one and the
smaller you can make this region the
more information you can get on a hard
disk and over the years material
scientists and chemists have managed to
make materials that get smaller and
smaller magnetic areas that can still be
read this is what we would call a single
molecule magnet and what this single
molecule magnet title means is that it
has a type of magnetism which is held
preferentially at a particular
temperature and it will hold that
magnetism but if it gets too warm then
it scrambles and it loses its preference
a few years ago people came up with
something they called single molecule
magnets which contained a relatively
small number of atom metal atoms which
were lined up and once these atoms had
been magnetized if they were at low
temperature they
could keep their magnetization it was
very cold only a few degrees above
absolute zero
but enough to demonstrate the effect so
if you can get individual molecules to
store your individual zeros and ones
you've increased the level of data
storage many hundreds of times probably
thousands of times the problem is
finding a single molecule magnet that
keeps its magnetization really well and
the transition metals iron particularly
manganese are very good with one
property but they have a different
property which is not so good for
getting the effect on the other hand the
lanthanide elements the rare earths have
the second property very good the first
one isn't so good and it looks as if the
uranium group the actinides has the two
properties together both reasonably good
neither is brilliant but the combination
is better than either the transition
metals or the rare earths so it could
actually be one of the best elements
available to do this and Steve has now
demonstrated the principle that you can
get uranium atoms which will couple
together in the way that you need for a
single molecule magnet the effect is
really quite striking the problem is
that it only curves at a really low
temperature so the temperature that it
works that is below two degrees absolute
which is absolutely hopeless if you
wanted to make a hard disk but it's a
first step are you suggesting that we
could have hard drives containing
uranium in the future I'm saying in the
future it might be possible whether
anybody actually wants a hard drive with
depleted uranium in it is an entirely
separate issue but from a does it work
yes or no perspective the answer
in the future yes it might be able to
work I think it's pretty unlikely that
you will have uranium in computers but
what I do think is that compounds like
this
again make chemists think and suddenly
they'll realize where we could do
something quite clever and get round the
fact that we don't need to use uranium
so this is our molecule here and you can
see a uranium there and the uranium
center there and then we've got these
quite big complicated ligands but
basically the uranium is bonded to one
carbon and two nitrogens and then it has
an iodide and then we've got this
bridging toluene molecule and then on
this side it's exactly the same as that
side what's that's a monster molecule
that is a monster molecule indeed